At this point, we've covered all of the essential pieces of
the memory system. Now, let's step back and put it all together.
To help us do this, I've written some pseudocode that captures the
strategy for loading data into the CPU. You can imagine that we're
writing an emulator if you like. The first thing that needs
to happen to a virtual address is for it to be converted
to a physical address. We'll postpone that until later. Then, if the
data is in the cache, we simply read from the cache otherwise,
we read from memory. Note that whenever we read from memory,
we also write to the cache evicting some block if necessary.
This process is, is what we talked about in the first
half of the lesson. The second half of the lesson was
largely concerned with address translation. The first place we check is
the tlb. If the physical page frame is there, then we're
done. If not, then we need to consult the page table.
Notice that none of these procedures that access the page table
should use the load procedure as it's defined here. The
top level page table cannot be in a paging system itself.
Otherwise, load would call translation, which would then end up
calling load again, which would end up calling translation and so
forth. We can imagine a fixed page being assigned to
store the top level of page table, another good reason for
making this small. I've made the check for the access
violation explicit here, because it's in the page table that this
is most likely to happen. It's possible that we would get
an access violation in the tlb if we try to read
a kernel page. But for the most part, the page simply
won't be there. If the present or valid bit isn't set
in the page table entry, that means that the page we
want isn't in memory. So, we raise a page_fault. This will
then be caught by the page handler, up here, and then
we can re-run the load procedure, and this time we will
find that it's in memory. And so we won't raise the page fault again. Obviously
this pseudocode has its limitations. By using just
software, we can't capture the interaction between the
OS and the hardware and we're abstracting away
many of the details. Nevertheless, if this makes
sense to you then you have a good
high-level idea of how a memory system operates.